en este vídeo quiero que pensemos en qué
es lo que ocurre cuando lanzamos algún
tipo de proyectil por ejemplo una pelota
o una roca qué pasa si yo lo lanzo hacia
arriba en el aire para esto voy a
graficar la distancia con respecto al
tiempo pero antes vamos a tener una
velocidad inicial
de velocidad inicial vector igual a 19.6
metros sobre segundo elegí esta cantidad
para que se nos faciliten un poquito los
cálculos más adelante
y vamos a tener que como la estamos
lanzando en el aire en el planeta tierra
pues bueno vamos a tener nuestra
velocidad o nuestra aceleración de la
gravedad
que es igual a 9.8 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado y valor también sabemos que
la fórmula para encontrar la fuerza de
atracción de graves de la gravedad entre
algún objeto y la tierra es la fuerza de
gravedad
es igual a la masa del objeto en la
superficie terrestre por g minúscula la
constante gravitatoria que es la que
vimos aquí
ahora si queremos conocer la aceleración
de la gravedad
bueno conocemos otra fórmula donde se
nos dice que
la aceleración
es igual a la fuerza entre la masa si
usamos esta fórmula
dentro de la sustituimos en esta otra
fórmula aquí nos va a quedar que
la fuerza
o si dividimos todo entre la masa para
dejar solita la fuerza
nos queda la fuerza
/ m es igual a la masa por la gravedad
entre esta misma masa
estas se cancelan y esta parte
esto
es lo mismo que esto entonces podemos
concluir que la aceleración en este caso
la aceleración va a ser igual a mi
constante gravitatoria a mi g minúscula
y esta minúscula viene de la ley de la
gravitación universal que es lo que
estuvimos viendo los vídeos anteriores y
que es tan fuerte como indica qué tan
fuerte es el campo gravitatorio cerca de
la superficie de la tierra y usando la
segunda ley de newton encontramos que la
aceleración de esta fuerza es igual a g
otra cosa que quiero mencionar es que
cuando hablamos de esta fuerza de
gravedad en general la ley de la
gravitación universal nos dice que si
tenemos una fuerza o que esta fuerza de
atracción entre dos cuerpos va a ser
igual a la constante gravitatoria g
mayúscula multiplicada por la masa o el
producto de la masa de los objetos y los
que queremos conocer cuál es la fuerza
gravitatoria y dividida
entre el cuadrado de la distancia que lo
separa y aquí ustedes me pueden decir
bueno es que la fuerza de gravedad
claramente está dependiendo de la
distancia entonces si yo estoy lanzando
algo hacia arriba pues esta distancia va
a cambiar y técnicamente ustedes tendrán
razón pero la realidad es que a lanzar
algo al aire el cambio en la distancia
es tan pequeño que pues realmente es
como si no existiera este cambio
entonces podemos simplificar los
cálculos asumiendo que está todos estos
elementos
y que estoy subrayando aquí
esta m es la masa del planeta tierra que
todos estos elementos son
lo mismo que nuestra constante nuestra
aceleración de la gravedad e minúscula
que hemos calculado aquí
entonces fuera nos queda esta
simplificación recordamos entonces que
la aceleración de la gravedad es este
valor 9.8 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado y debo aclarar que estas son
cantidades vectoriales en esta ocasión
la convención es que si alguna cosa se
mueve hacia arriba hay bueno me quedo un
poco chocó si algo se mueve hacia arriba
va a ser una cantidad positiva si algo
se mueve hacia abajo va a tener una
cantidad negativa
por algo para algo que está en caída
libre la gravedad lo va a traer hacia
abajo así que para indicar la dirección
de la aceleración de la gravedad vamos a
usar el signo menos indicando negativo
que va hacia abajo entonces tenemos la
aceleración de la gravedad
es igual a menos 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado
ahora vamos a graficar la velocidad
contra el tiempo y veremos cómo
determinar una fórmula en la que si
tenemos como entrada el tiempo como una
variable independiente podemos obtener
la distancia asumiendo estos valores
iniciales pero antes de graficar el
desplazamiento contra el tiempo vamos a
encontrar algunas fórmulas vemos que
queremos también encontrar el
desplazamiento entonces de los vídeos
anteriores vimos que el desplazamiento
es igual a la velocidad promedio
velocidad promedio
víctor todos estos son vectores
multiplicado por el cambio en el tiempo
o la diferencia en el tiempo y también
vemos que la velocidad promedio
la velocidad promedio pues que viene
siendo la velocidad promedio va a ser
igual a la velocidad final más la
velocidad inicial entre 2
y seguimos insistiendo son vectores y
esto sólo funciona si y sólo si tenemos
una aceleración constante como estamos
trabajando con la aceleración de la
gravedad esta no va a cambiar entonces
aquí es si podemos usar esta este
promedio de la velocidad entonces bueno
vamos a expresar esto no conocemos cuál
es nuestra velocidad final entonces
tenemos que encontrar una manera de
expresar esto sin tener que
tener este valor como podemos expresar
la velocidad final
bueno vamos a trabajar desde terminar
que nuestra velocidad promedio
va a ser igual a la velocidad inicial
más algo que todavía no sé que sea y va
a estar dividido entre dos y aparte
hemos visto que nuestra velocidad final
a esta velocidad final
es igual a la velocidad inicial
más la aceleración por el cambio en el
tiempo es decir comienzo con una
velocidad inicial y esta parte me va a
indicar cuánto he avanzado o cuánto he
acelerado durante cierto período de
tiempo entonces si sumo esto en mi
velocidad inicial pues me voy a quedar
en mi velocidad final o la velocidad que
tengo hasta un tiempo dado en un cierto
tiempo establecido
entonces bueno aquí tengo esta velocidad
final expresado de esta manera de manera
que lo voy a sustituir aquí y me va a
quedar entonces que esta velocidad
inicial va a ser igual a la velocidad
inicial
más
la aceleración por el cambio en el
tiempo
entonces es esto que obtuvimos aquí
es lo que estoy sustituyendo en este
valor para este la velocidad final
hacia acá
y bueno vamos a simplificar esta
expresión entonces tenemos
la velocidad promedio
es igual
dos veces velocidad inicial más
velocidad inicial
dos veces la velocidad inicial entre 2
más
vamos a ponerle otro color más
esta parte que es la aceleración por el
cambio en el tiempo
entre 2
esta es una manera de expresar la
velocidad promedio ya que bueno no
conocemos la velocidad final y todo esto
lo tenemos que multiplicar entonces
ahora usando esta velocidad promedio en
nuestra fórmula del desplazamiento
entonces todo esto
lo vamos a sustituir aquí voy a tener
el desplazamiento igual a mi velocidad
promedio que resulta ser esto lo
simplificamos un poco es igual a la
velocidad
inicial
más la aceleración
por el cambio en el tiempo
esto entre 2
y todo esto lo voy a multiplicar
por el cambio en el tiempo
este beca
entonces vamos a desarrollar esta
fórmula y nos va a quedar entonces
nuestro desplazamiento
igual a velocidad
inicial
por el cambio en el tiempo que estoy
multiplicando aquí
más
la mitad o un medio de la aceleración
por el cambio en el tiempo al cuadrado y
esta es nuestra fórmula de la del
desplazamiento
esta fórmula también la pueden encontrar
si no estamos hablando de vectores
pueden encontrar esta fórmula así
distancia es igual a nuestra velocidad
inicial
aquí para mantener los colores velocidad
inicial por el tiempo
más
en medio de la aceleración por el tiempo
al cuadrado esta es la misma pero aquí
están viendo cómo se llega a esta
fórmula y no es necesario que ustedes la
memoricen pueden este llegar a ella
mediante este razonamiento y bueno vamos
a usar esta fórmula de desplazamiento
para hacer la gráfica
con respecto del espaciamiento con
respecto al tiempo y esto lo vamos a ver
en el siguiente vídeo